and so much is just luck jon snow is a
very skilled combatant but part of the
reason he survives this battle is just
he gets lucky a lot of the mistakes were
very basic elemental um writing mistakes
you know going back to the very first
geometric pattern on the show which was
the weird array of body parts that the
white walkers made
these are patterns that have mystical
significance for the children the forest
we're not sure exactly what they signify
but spiral patterns are important a lot
of different cultures in our world then
make sense that they would be in this
world as well
they're starting to be attracted to each
other and so much of it is not from
dialogue or anything we wrote it's just
the two of them in a small space
standing near each other and us just
watching that and feeling the heat of
that
jamie's charge at daenerys is a hard
thing to top jamie's charge at daenerys
is a hard thing to top there was the
idea that bringing one of these things
down south had been put out there before
in a way that didn't work but in theory
you could bring one of these things down
and have it still functional by the time
it gets to king's landing that seemed
like that would on a story level do the
trick
like many of these situations on the
show the one who figures it out is
tyrion the only way you're going to
prove it to people is to show it to
people
many of his plans have really gone awry
if tyrion has a flaw
he's very clever man but sometimes
clever people
overestimate their own cleverness at a
certain point you have to find the army
of the dead we were thinking how can you
possibly survive that situation that was
the thing that was the hardest for us
and then you put five or ten thousand
whites on that ice coming after them
that that might believably be something
that would break the ice in a way that
they didn't he sees that they're all
gonna die if the dragon doesn't take off
the rational decision at that point is
you guys go to safety and i'll try to
keep them off you as long as i can
he's the guy who jumps on the grenade to
save the rest of the platoon that's
always been john
sansanoria in the earlier episodes of
the season where you really believe that
one will potentially kill the other it's
one of the benefits of working on a show
like this where over the years so many
beloved characters have been killed and
so many characters make decisions you
wish they hadn't that you can believe
that sanso might conspire against arya
or that arya might decide that sansa has
betrayed the family and deserves to die
what they see is just the end of the
dothraki essentially
[Music]
she seemed like the best candidate
provided we weren't thinking about her
in that moment we hoped to kind of avoid
the expected and jon snow has always
been the hero the one who's in the
savior but it
just didn't seem right to us for this
for this moment while danny kind of
forgot about the iron fleet and euron's
forces they certainly haven't forgotten
about her and they're just waiting for
her to come back then you go to hbo you
make a pilot which didn't they did not
run no we made every possible we've
never done this before
so we had messed up the the most kind of
obvious storytelling possibilities how
many millions of dollars you think they
wasted on that first pilot i think about
10.6
about 10.2 we went into with no
experience uh in television whatsoever
and
it made a tremendous number of mistakes
for the first year i mean still make
mistakes every year i think you know we
didn't have any experience producing a
television show or a movie or an
internet special or anything we've never
done anything really that unfounded
ridiculous faith in you guys
but almost it's almost called foolish
faith
we're both kind of geographically
challenged we don't have a very good
sense of where we are in space and this
year for the first time we've
been there for the first time we got
some pushback where the actor said um
you sure about that guess who it is
so there was a long conversation and we
got a long letter explaining why this
was a bad idea which just made us want
to kill that person that much more so
you know
you like you can't kill them off don't
don't do that yeah unless i just go
drive somewhere
stop putting pieces on the board for the
most part and start you know playing
with with the pieces that were already
there possible we should have made that
decision like a season earlier
[Music]
it's gonna be bigger now that it's only
gonna be seven or eight episodes it will
be bigger
and it will also be worse
but mostly better
like with terms of fantasy exposition
and you know we tried to keep that stuff
to a minimum because we didn't just want
it to appeal to a fantasy
fan base we wanted them to love it and
we wanted parents to love it and people
who played professional football to love
it did bran know that arya was going to
kill the night king
possibly and there are a few scenes and
stormy swords that
i didn't see them coming and and when i
went back and re-read them the clues are
there it's not the kind of it's not a
you know the random surprise where you
couldn't see it coming because
westeros doesn't belong to anybody
nobody has a history of family in
westeros nobody is personally connected
to it and that means that everybody can
be equally connected to it we've got two
seasons left i think it was a kind of
indefinite end there there would be a
bit of fatigue creeping in it's very
hard to work on something for
364 and a half days a year for 10 years
without
feeling like it's your own you always
start with the best of intentions you're
gonna be faithful
you know forever and then
you start to have some other ideas and
you start to stray a little bit you want
to try to avoid getting put into any
kind of niche if you've done a fantasy
series okay those are the fantasy guys
so
and
i think after this one's done i can't
really imagine doing another once we
realized that both john and tyrion were
inevitably going to be prisoners we went
through a number of different versions
of how to best take advantage of that
tension and we finally landed on the
version we had
in the dragon pit
why do you think i came all this way
you